IT'S TIME TO PLAY ETSY PITCHMAN.
THE ARRAY OF BIZARRE HANDMADE
PRODUCTS ON ETSY HAVE TAUGHT US
THAT YOU CAN BE INSANE AND GROSS
PERVO AND STILL BE A REMARKABLY
SKILLED AT CRAFTING.
COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
A REAL PRODUCT AVAILABLE ON SALE
ON ETSY, AND FOR 250 POINTS, I
WOULD LIKE A TAGLINE TO HELP
SELL IT.
FIRST ONE: THIS DEAD BABY SKULL
DIP HOLDER.
DONALD.
>> PERFECT FOR THREATENING YOUR
KIDS.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
DEON.
>> DON'T KNOW WHAT TO BUY AMANDA
BYNES FOR CHRISTMAS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
I WOULD GIVE YOU POINTS FOR THAT
ONE.
NEXT ONE.
THIS CHINESE MADE SUIT.
IT'S LIKE A WET SUIT BUT FOR
[BEEP].
ELIZA.
>> WELL, SINCE IT'S BLACK AND IT
WON'T STAIN --
>> OH.
>> NO! NO!
>> HERE WE GO!
>> ALL I HEARD WAS "SINCE IT'S
BLACK."
>> WELL IT MEANS IT WON'T STAIN.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S TRUE. THAT'S TRUE.
>> SO, YOU CAN EASILY JUST DO A
QUICK TOSS OFF, HOSE OFF AND
HEAD TO CHURCH.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, THAT'S
FINE.
POINTS.
OF COURSE POINTS.
>> CHRIS: NEXT ONE: THIS
PROSTHETIC MAN PIG MASK.
OH, DEAR SWEET LORD.
YES, DEON.
>> YOU WANT TO SCARE THE DRUG
DEALERS ON YOUR BLOCK.
[LAUGHING]
>> YOU CAN BE A REAL PIG.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NEXT ONE THIS BULK ORDER OF
SPENT TOILET PAPER ROLLS.
YES, DEON.
>> A BOX OF GENERIC PUSSY
POCKETS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
YES.
NOW OF COURSE EVERYONE KNOWS
THAT WHEN YOU'RE SHOPPING AT A
SEX STORE, IN THE ISLE THE TOP
ISLES HAVE THE NAME BRANDS, BUT
THE BOTTOM HAS A BAG OF
>> -- GENERIC ONES.
>> CHRIS: THERE'S LIKE A QUALA
BEAR ON IT -- IT'S PUSS-POUCH,
OR WHATEVER, IT'S NOT A
NAME-BRAND. DONALD.
>> FOR $11 I'LL SELL YOU THE
PAPER.
[LAUGHING]
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
ELIZA.
>> HEY, POOR KIDS, HERE ARE SOME
TELESCOPES.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS. SO GOOD.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> CHRIS: NICE -- NEXT ONE THIS
CATBOY SEX DOLL.
[LAUGHING]
DEON.
>> FINALLY A PUSSY THAT [BEEP]
YOU.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.